Intro
So sind wir das erste Mal im Salon. Ich glaube es gefällt mir ganz gut es raucht ein bisschen.
Das Licht ist gedimmt allerdings die Anzug und Krawatte Pflicht ist schon überwunden zumindest bei mir.
Bei mir ist.
Wolfgang natürlich in Schale ist ja klar Selbst für Audio only.
Bevor wir Texte lesen. Du hast ja Filme geguckt und ich hatte mir eigentlich vorgenommen auch einen zu gucken nämlich 1917 weil du argumentiert hast das ist wie Let's Play.
Und es hat mich ein bisschen getriggert weil ehrlich gesagt ich gucke ganz gerne Let's Plays Ich habe so meine Lieblings Let's Play.
Und es ist für mich ein Argument dafür mir den Film anzugucken wenn du sagst dass es eigentlich Play.
Das war auch keine Kritik daran sondern dieser Film bzw.
Der Regisseur Sam Mendes hat verstanden dass man diese ästhetik aufgreifen kann dass man aber wenn man sie ins Filmische ins Kino überführt damit etwas ganz anderes schafft nämlich die Frage,
Wie ist es eigentlich als Zuschauer der ja zu Passivität im Kino verdammt ist.
Zuschauer zu Passivität mitzukriegen.
Bei einem Film mit zu fiebern wo es ganz stark darum geht etwas rechtzeitig zu schaffen nicht vom Gegner abgefeuert zu werden.
Der Film spielt im Ersten Weltkrieg es gibt da eine Mission Es wird also wirklich nur eine winzige Episode aus diesem großen Krieg erzählt und das wird aus einer mit einer Kamera gemacht.
Erzählt. Und das wird aus einer mit einer Kamera gemacht.
Ohne sichtbaren Schnitt gab es ein paar Schnitte aber ohne sichtbaren Schnitt.
Ohne sichtbaren Schritt aber sichtbar.
Und das ist eine cineastische Meisterleistung aber auch ein sehr reflektierter kluger Film über den Ersten Weltkrieg.
Und für mich eine große überraschung.
Und das hab ich nur gelesen. Ich hätte mir dann auch angucken die entwickeln ich gehen wirklich immer nur in eine Richtung man kein Setting zweimal vorbei oder so sondern das zieht sich wirklich.
Ja genau.
Ich kann nicht verstehen wie man es hergestellt hat. Ich habe so ein Making of gesehen fand es unglaublich aber so macht man jetzt mittlerweile Filme um sich zu unterscheiden von anderen Produktionen diese stattfinden.
Das ist nicht schlecht und gelesen hast du auch. Was hast du denn gelesen. Zu Anfang unseres.
Gelesen.
Ich fange mal an wir haben ja in unserer ersten Podcast Folge schon darüber gesprochen dass der Klimawandel angekommen ist inzwischen in der Wirtschaft angekommen ist das ist aber keineswegs so sein wird dass Klimaschutz jetzt,
antikapitalistisch sein wird ganz im Gegenteil Das System erneuert sich gerade und man kann es an einem sehr schönen Detail sehen.
Da gab es einen Artikel im Freitag zu dem Titel Klima Ring für Kopenhagen von Richard Orange ist dieser Artikel und der erzählt davon dass jetzt sehr viele Küstenstädte zum Beispiel Kopenhagen aber auch in Singapur und so weiter findet statt,
sich überlegen Wie reagieren wir auf den steigenden Meeresspiegel Jetzt könnte man sagen Wir bauen Deiche Wir bauen eben alles ein,
dass wir geschützt sind wir brauchen so eine Front.
Und dann sagt man Nein man baut jetzt vor vielen Küstenstädten Inseln auf künstliche.
Um dadurch diese quasi wie ein Deich funktionieren die dann die Städte schützen die zugleich aber nach vorne hin so hoch sind dass sie eben diese Wassermassen dann auch abhalten.
Aber wie finanziert man das Ganze jetzt und das hat man da sieht man wie intelligent der Kapitalismus ist. Ja das ist ja wunderbar.
Es entsteht neues Land in bester Lage kann man sagen ja mit Seeblick Man hat dort diese künstlichen Inseln die eben,
mit dem Festland verbunden sind aber eben nur sehr lose und das Festland hat weiterhin auch seine Küste nicht sodass man jetzt einfach,
wegnimmt und das.
Errichtet der Staat.
Aber zugleich sind Investoren dort die in Immobilien investieren die dort bauen wollen und das ist so eine null null Rechnung am Ende kostet es so viel wie es dann auch wieder einbringt.
Weil der Wohnungsmarkt boomt ja überall gerade an solchen Orten gerade in diesen Städten.
Und damit hat man es geschafft einen Schutz zu bieten vor denen vor dem steigenden Meeresspiegel und hat auch schon wieder ein gutes Geschäft mit Immobilien.
Nicht alle sind dafür aber in Kopenhagen machen wir es jetzt gerade Niederlande sträubt sich.
Das ist alles nachzulesen in diesem sehr sehr interessanten Artikel und dann auch in Singapur geht man ähnlich vor und wir werden noch viele solche Dinge erleben wie man auf den Klimawandel reagiert.
Eine Frage noch dazu. Man baut einen Damm aber nicht auf Land sondern vorher ins Wasser sodass man diese exponierte Wohnlage dann auch noch einmal separiert von der eigentlichen Hektik der Stadt hat.
Natürlich hat mich so ein bisschen in Frankfurt wird jetzt eine Autobahn Teilstück überbrückt über Tunnel über Tunnels.
Interessantes dass man sich fragt Wie kriegen wir das finanziert.
Wir machen nicht einfach nur den Deckel drauf sondern wir machen den Deckel richtig fest sodass darauf Wohnraum entsteht.
Und jetzt hat man ein Milliardenprojekt bei dem man auch hofft dass es sich von selbst finanziert weil der Ort der dann plötzlich stillgelegt gut sitzt zum Wohnen eignet ist natürlich sowieso dann beruhigt weil an die Autobahn ran hat ja bisher noch keiner gebaut.
Also auf die Autobahn raus drauf baust acht Stockwerke oder so wollen sie bauen.
Nochmal sozusagen Puffer der bisher Frage wie man es so verdichtet ob das immer so bleiben wird. Aber so ist natürlich hervorragend.
Was hast du gelesen.
Ich habe als allererstes einen Text von Alan Rusbridger gelesen.
Der Name sagt dir bestimmt was denn das war mal der Guardian Chefredakteur. Damals als Glenn Greenwald nicht wusste wohin mit Snowdens Dokumenten da dabei Alan Rusbridger den Anknüpfungspunkt gefunden deshalb sehr viel damals im Guardian publiziert wurde.
Er hat jetzt einen Text geschrieben über die Gründe warum dieses Verhältnis zu den Royals zu den Royals in England so merkwürdig ist und er möchte gern darüber aufklären.
Über Sachen die man in der Zeitung nicht liest.
Das ist besonders interessant weil jetzt das Verhältnis zwischen denen der royalen Familie und den britischen Bürgern geklärt wird weil dazwischen stehen ja die Medien.
Man sieht ja nicht wirklich die royale Familie sondern die Medien dazwischen und dieser Text handelt davon wie natürlich Harry und Macan jetzt mit ihrem Maxis gehen jetzt nach Kanada zumindest erst einmal dieses eine Jahr haben sie jetzt frei bekommen danach wird neu verhandelt.
Sie sind natürlich ein interessantes Paar klar sie sind zweitens königlich und drittens alles was wir über die Royals wissen wissen wir über Journalisten die ihrerseits alles nur aus Hörensagen Quellen kennen.
Es geht um Haus der Familie um Pelléas Insiders und Francks als Quelle und so weiter.
Und da wird so eine Dimension ausgeblendet dass nämlich die Journalisten nicht immer Ansprechpartner finden sondern sehr oft einfach mal das Telefon hacken oder sonst sich irgendwie einschleichen also wirklich grenzüberschreitend sind.
Und Alan Rusbridger nennt hier mal die Zahlen und das ist jetzt wirklich beeindruckend.
Alleine die Mirror Group und alles rund um Murdock,
beläuft sich mittlerweile auf eine Milliarde Pfund die die Medienhäuser der Kirche Schulden oder schon gezahlt haben weil die Skandale über gehackte Telefone und so niemals vor Gericht geklärt werden.
Krone-Schmalz.
Diese Skandale werden niemals vor Gericht geklärt weil die Verlage immer vorher zurückziehen weil sie wollen das Urteil Vermeiden Sie wollen nicht dass es wird dann lieber Stillschweigen so wie VW mit den geschädigten Autofahrern umgeht.
Es sind mittlerweile Milliarden Werte die zwischen den Journalisten zwischen den interessierten und der königlichen Familie stehen.
Sind Milliarden Interessen haben sich angehäuft und dadurch hat man so eine Konstellation dass die Medienhäuser auf der einen Seite süchtig sind nach der royalen Familie und sie gleichzeitig abgrundtief hassen weil die Chefs immer wissen wie teuer so etwas ist.
Dieses Interesse zu befriedigen.
Das angebliche Interesse dieses Gerede der Interesse. Da kann man bei Alan Rusbridger mal nachlesen wie sich das Verhältnis so ist.
Die Verleger sind besessen von der royalen Familie gleichzeitig hassen sie sie und die Journalisten stehen in einem doppelten Konflikt.
Zum einen in diesem juristischen Konflikt mit der königlichen Familie und in einem ökonomischen Konflikt mit den Leuten die nicht mehr bereit sind für Journalismus zu bezahlen sondern auf diese Headlines warten.
Und vielleicht kann man den Text auch ein bisschen unter Chiffre Gesichtspunkten lesen.
Dass es hier nicht nur um die königliche Familie gehen muss sondern so ist auch das Verhältnis mit der Politik allgemein.
Die Könige waren natürlich die Politiker von damals ist ein Interesse übrig geblieben aber der Umgang mit der Umgang mit Merkel und so weiter.
Da steckt ein bisschen was zwischen den Zeilen in diesem Text drin dass man vielleicht mal ein bisschen bewusst machen sollte.
Gut ist natürlich im Guardian erschienen wo sonst.
Ich habe nach langer Zeit wieder eine Zeitschrift gelesen die ich lange nicht gelesen habe nämlich Melodie und Rhythmus Magazin für Gegenkultur.
Das ist ein Magazin das sich mit popkulturelle Gegenkultur und mit alldem auseinandersetzt aus einer linken Perspektive.
Und die haben jetzt ein Heft mit dem Schwerpunkt ökologie das sehr sehr gut ist denn sie beschäftigen sich dort auch mit der Frage ob der Kapitalismus diese ganzen ökologischen Fragen lösen wird können.
Die Antwort lautet Eher nein. Da gibt es übrigens auch einen Text von Dietmar dazu Ich empfehle aber ausdrücklich einen viel besseren Text nämlich den.
Grünen Caja der beschäftigt sich mit Science-Fiction-Filmen auch eine Frage die wir mal im Podcast behandelt haben.
Und er macht das anhand von Downsizing nun Mut und zeigt dass die ökologische Krise,
sehr gut durch diese Filme auch mit Marx lesbar wird und dass es also eine Antwort geben muss auf die ökologische Frage,
die eher antikapitalistisch ist und auch sonst sind einige andere wichtige Texte drin über die ökonomische Nutzbarmachung von Naturkatastrophen wie,
der Kapitalismus von Ausbeutung profitiert und das ist aber auch immer wieder zurück gespiegelt auf gewisse kulturelle gegen kulturelle Erzeugnisse die es so gibt.
Eine ganz ganz interessante Ausgabe die obwohl viele jetzt auch schon fast so häufig,
vorkommen mit diesem Thema ökologie nochmal einige ganz neue Aspekte beleuchtet die so im Mainstream Diskurs eher weniger stattfinden.
Du hast in einem echten Papier gelesen dass das ihr.
Die habe ich auf echtem Papier gelesen es gibt sie bestimmt auch als Paper oder zum Teil auch etwas online aber ich kaufe auch hin und wieder noch Zeitschriften und lese sie.
Ja ich habe Florian Illies wie in der letzten angesprochen auch gekauft für 500 Euro allerdings nicht auf Papier.
Da bin ich doch umweltbewusst genug.
Gut die New York Times hat einen Text geschrieben der heißt Sekrete Company might might Privacy.
Die geheime das geheime Unternehmen das in der Lage ist,
die Privatsphäre als Prinzip zu beenden jedenfalls so wie wir sie kennen ist ein Text von Kashmir Hill.
Dem haben wir hoffentlich alle gehört und ich will trotzdem mal kurz darauf eingehen was hier drinsteht weil das ist ungeheuerlich.
Also der Text entstieg ist wie folgt Es gibt einen australischen Taki der heißt Huan Tonn that kommt wahrscheinlich irgendwo aus diesem asiatischen Raum.
Er hat mal eine App geschrieben mit der man ein Selfie von sich macht und dann kann man sich Donald Trumps Frisur aufsetzen. Passgenau ist natürlich ein Brüller.
So etwas zieht natürlich wenn auch nur für einen Abend da lassen sich das dann alle runter.
Und dann als nächste App hat da eine Suchmaschine für Gesichter geschrieben und es ist gar nicht so raffiniert weil ja im Grunde die technischen Vorlagen genommen wie sie in der Wissenschaft publiziert sind so macht man das halt Augenabstand Nase und so weiter.
Und der Text führt dann führt dann aus warum das FBI Homeland Security und die Local Police.
Und da kann man natürlich ein Plural von 600 an der Zahl sprechen warum die Software plötzlich genutzt haben Gesichtserkennung ist nichts Neues das als App im Grunde Instagram macht das diese ganzen Filter und so weiter funktionieren genauso.
Und die Polizei benutzt diese Software ohne und es ist der erste kecker im Text ohne zu wissen wo sie herkam.
Die Polizisten einfach Ja das ist so eine Art Orakel das gab es damals schon mal bei den Snowden-Enthüllungen.
Die Polizei wenn sie mal nicht weiter wusste hatte immer lokal dann ein Typ dem konnte man nochmal so eine Frage auf den Tisch legen und der hatte Kontakt zum Geheimdienst und da wurde auch intern immer so als das Orakel.
Also wenn bei uns mal so Ermittlungsarbeit bremst dann legen wir dem so eine Fragestellung auf den Tisch dann wissen wir gar nicht was da passiert und eine Woche später gibts plötzlich so eine magische Antwort.
Da wurde nämlich mal das NSA der Daten Fusionsreaktor angefragt. Und genau so ist das ja auch.
Ich hab keine Ahnung Die Stadt hat plötzlich zur Verfügung und habe die genutzt da die Polizei die gekauft.
Naja plötzlich hat man diese Software benutzt und das ist eben dieser juristische Dammbruch dass man erstens der Software genutzt hat ohne zu wissen wo sie herkam Man hatte gar keine legitime Berechtigung und der zweite Tabubruch.
Bild Datenbank die genutzt wurde waren nicht nur die öffentlichen Datenbanken also öffentlich im Sinne von Behörden öffentlich.
Das FBI kommt zum Beispiel auf eine eigene Datenbank mit 411 Millionen Bilder sondern diese App Zugriff auf einen Datenbestand von drei Milliarden Bildern zurück indem sie sich einfach bei Social Media bedient hat also der Dreh und Angelpunkt ist hier nicht oh diese Technik war in dem Fall so gefährlich,
wie sonst nichts sondern die Algorithmen waren Standard Algorithmen aber der Datenbestand der,
da genutzt wurde der war eben einfach Social-Media und diese Art von öffentlichkeits Rasterfahndung Möglichkeiten hat man auch in Amerika eigentlich bislang nicht genutzt.
Da gab es immer noch so eine Sperre das war für die Polizei eigentlich nicht so möglich die App heißt clear fast wie aus einem Romania wie bei Dave Eggers Irgendwie ist sie halt und sie hat ganz bewusst die AGB gebrochen beispielsweise von Facebook.
Facebook lässt diese automatisierte Nutzung nicht zu.
Als die New York Times dann anfing da hinterher zu recherchieren hat man festgestellt Auf der Website des Anbieters steht überhaupt nur ein Name und dazu eine Adresse in Manhattan die es nicht gibt.
Also 600 Polizeibehörden nutzen eine App von einem Hersteller der offenbar eine Briefkastenfirma betreibt.
Das ist schon mal komisch vorkommen und dann hat die Journalistin angefangen.
Oder was ein Journalist Kashmir Hill.
Kashmir. Wahrscheinlich jedenfalls. Der Journalist ging dann los zu dieser Polizei und hat gesagt,
Gebt doch mal mein Bild Bilder ein Mal gucken was passiert oder Sucht doch mal nach mir macht ein Foto von mir und guckt mal welche Verbindung so herauskommt wer bin ich denn. Wenn du nur ein Foto von mir hast.
Daraufhin hat die Polizei angefangen zu recherchieren.
Plötzlich bekam die Polizei einen Anruf von dem Hersteller ihr sucht da jemanden mit der Person gesprochen oder der Hersteller der Software hat schon herausgefunden.
Da gibt's einen Journalisten der es hinter mir her und in dem Moment wo die Polizisten anfingen nach dieser Person zu suchen haben sie sich der Hersteller nämlich die Polizei überwacht.
Bei der Polizei gemeldet und nachgefragt habt ihr schon was gesagt. Oder können wir noch weitermachen wie bisher.
Das ist haarsträubend.
Darüber wurde dann endlich mal der Kontakt hergestellt Ton der davon sprach ja das ist ein Prototyp für Augmented Reality gedacht aber dann gab mir die Gelegenheit dass wir einfach anfingen Polizisten zu verkaufen.
Da gab es ein Interesse und ein Budget dann wurde das halt einfach installiert bei den Polizisten und die Polizei hat dann selbst erst mal mitbekommen im Moment.
Also wir werden hier auch gerade überwacht. Der Hersteller überwacht uns gerade wie wir da ist ein bisschen ans Tageslicht gezogen und dann stellt sich heraus wie ein Gründer Richard Schwarz der Freund von Rudolph Giuliani.
Der erste Finanzier dieses ganzen Unterfangens ist Peter Thiel also enge Verknüpfung zu Trump,
und Facebook Investment. So steckt da ganz ganz ganz tief drin.
Mit.
Richtig mit Elon Musk Paypal gegründet und so gab es noch einen zweiten Finanzier. Der heißt David sagte.
Dystopien Future what you can Banat also genau was wir vorher besprachen.
Klar kann es sein dass es in die Dystopie führt aber verhindern können sie es auch nicht.
Also lieber machen das ganze Ding läuft jetzt seit drei Jahren.
2016 wurde das gegründet und direkt an Polizei vermarktet.
Über republikanische Politiker die beispielsweise aus der Polizei sich selbst rekrutieren.
Es gibt ja sehr viele Wahlkämpfe hier gab es zum Beispiel einen Wahlkampf um die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in Alabama und die Wahlkampfleiter.
Da war eine Vertreterin also quasi Vertreterin die so Kontakt hergestellt hat für das Unternehmen zur Polizei.
Also eine ganz enge Verknüpfung schon von diesem ganzen Kram wirklich gruselig zu lesen.
Da muss man echt sagen Der technische Teil ist nicht der diese institutionelle Verknüpfung zeigt auch wieder und das wird im Text eben nicht diskutiert.
Wie abhängig die Behörden von Facebook sind.
Als hätte Facebook den Auftrag bekommen lasst mal bitte die eure Bilder abgrasen damit wir unsere Polizeiarbeit machen können.
Da gab es ein ganz großes politisches Interesse es nicht zu unterbinden was hat illegalerweise stattfand,
auch nicht im Text diskutiert wird dass die Technologie selbst natürlich vorhanden ist und dass es sehr viele Unternehmen auf der Welt gibt die das beherrschen.
Und wenn die sich einfach so frech wären und den öffentlichen Datenbestand nehmen dann könnten die genau das Gleiche machen. Es gibt da.
In diesem Weltspiegel Beitrag den nur kurz zitiert haben wird es auch für Russland gezeigt dass solche Möglichkeiten dort auch bestehen.
Genau die Technik ist nicht mal die Herausforderung sondern es ist jetzt einfach das institutionelle der Umgang damit auch der juristische.
Da gibt es noch ein sehr schönes Zitat von Professor Privacy Prof.
Das ist in Stanford einer Kohl der meinte Monopoly ohne Macht.
Es gibt kein Monopol für Mathe und das ist natürlich hier besonders erwähnenswert auch noch erwähnenswert aber das nur weil es zeitlich passt es ist eben besonders witzig dass dies eine Veranstaltung gab,
wo Menschen eine persönliche Einladung bekamen und dann eingeladen wurden und,
sich das Westwall Team genau solche Technologien bedient hat und zu sagen Wir gehen jetzt mal wir machen jetzt mal Open Source Intelligence und suchen uns alle Inhalte über eine Person aus die wir finden,
und dann sitzen die Leute bei uns am Tisch und wir bringen das Gespräch direkt mit der privatesten persönlichsten Frage die uns überhaupt nur vorstellt wie gehts deiner Mutter.
Hat sie sich wieder mit Tante und so verstand.
Du hast doch vor drei Wochen Forsberg diesen post geschrieben.
Da kann man in so seltenen Momenten glaub ich auch nachvollziehen wie sich sowas niederschlägt in so einer realen Welt wenn man so einer Situation ausgesetzt ist.
Dieser Text umrahmt ganz wunderbar. Welche Tabus und welche Technologien mittlerweile in welchem Verhältnis zueinander stehen.
Und Hinzufügen muss man auch. Es löst keinen politischen Skandal in der öffentlichkeit aus. Es werden sicherlich manche Leute belangt.
Dann können auch die Demokraten Druck machen auf die Republikaner die sich darauf eingelassen haben die.
Kopierbar offenbar auch in der öffentlichkeit interessiert das relativ wenig.
Dieser Artikel wurde zwar viel geteilt und man hat ihn zur Kenntnis genommen aber es ist nicht so dass das jetzt etwas auslöst irgendeinen Zuspruch von Donald Trump der viel mehr hyperventilieren ist als das was jetzt,
viel massiver ist und viel gefährlicher ist als irgendein alternder Präsident der sich noch nochmal den einen oder anderen Spruch erlaubt aber das ist.
Auch ein bisschen versuchen gegenzusteuern indem wir auch andere Dinge in den Fokus rücken.
Und so will ich das auch mit einem anderen Text tun der ist in der Republik eben dieses Schweizer Portal für Qualitätsjournalismus der es frei verfügbar im Netz.
Dieser Text heißt das perfekte Bordell von einer Autorin die sich darüber Gedanken macht wie könnte es aussehen das perfekte Bordell denn wir haben ja zum einen wenn wir über Prostitution sprechen,
ganz viel Zwangsprostitution Wir haben die Ausbeutung von Frauen im höchsten Maße.
Zugleich ist aber Prostitution ein Phänomen das zum einen immer bestanden hat und das sich auch nicht einfach auflösen wird auch nicht durch Verbote auflösen wird.
Zugleich gibt es aber auch Sexarbeiterinnen die sagen Ich mache das weil ich das machen will. Nicht alle werden dazu gezwungen.
Sie stellt so eine Utopie auf Wie könnte das Bordell der Zukunft aussehen das müsste beispielsweise in der Stadt sein das müsste zentraler sein in Koblenz wo ich wohne ist der Straßenstrich.
Ins Industriegebiet verlagert so dass man das möglichst nicht mitbekommt.
Sie sagt Das ist ein ganz großes Problem denn dadurch verlieren natürlich auch die Behörden erst einmal Einfluss darauf was los ist aber es macht auch daraus etwas Anrüchiges.
Nicht nur für die die da reingehen sondern auch die da arbeiten und sie sagt sie will das Bordell wieder in die Gesellschaft holen will auch ein.
Bordell anbieten mit einer hohen Diversität auch mit verschiedenen Möglichkeiten das aber auch sehr transparent gemacht wird welche Wünsche und Begehren kann man dort haben Wie sehen die einzelnen Dienstleistungen aus.
Es gibt Preise Es gibt eine sehr faire Bezahlung Es gibt nicht diese Abhängigkeit wie sie in Bordellen ist dass die Frauen gezwungen werden gewisse Dinge zu machen nur weil sie dringend noch etwas Geld verdienen müssen.
Es ist also ein langer Text den ich insofern auch wichtig finde als wir 20 in den 20er Jahren auch sehr neu über Sexualität nachdenken werden.
Vielleicht weil die Sexualität und Reproduktion sich noch weiter trennen werden durch künstliche Formen der Reproduktion.
Das wird sicherlich noch Thema werden aber auch weil wir.
Durch die Digitalisierung und die digitalen Möglichkeiten eine ganz neue Form der Verfügbarkeit von sexuellen Partnern von Dienstleistungen die wir sehr einfach,
ohne hochgestellten Kragen irgendwo im Bahnhofsviertel herumzutragen an.
Die wir annehmen können und wir können auch überlegen wie weit sich sowieso das verschiebt,
Prostitution wo sind da die genauen Grenzen wenn man daran denkt dass es unglaublich viele Videoplattformen pornografische gibt wo Amateure sind die,
für wenig Geld sich ausziehen oder sonst was und das sind keine Leute die davon leben sondern dass man sich gerade noch die 50 Dollar oder was sie da mitnehmen.
Das verwischt sich alles sehr stark und es ist ein Text der einmal anders über das Modell nachdenkt weil wir jetzt schon sehr viele Texte hatten Gegner der Prostitution und dann gab es ein paar Prostituierte die sich selbst zu Wort gemeldet haben und gesagt haben Ich mache das gern.
Das ist jetzt eher so die Idee eines Bordells als utopischer Ort.
Und auch wir werden das Bordell noch einmal in ganz neuer Form erleben denn was wir hier alles gesehen haben sind eigentlich Gadgets die auf Dauer die Menschen unglücklich machen werden.
Und sie werden Bordelle aufsuchen wie sie Therapeuten aufsuchen da bin ich gewiss und ich habe mal mit einem Bordellbetreiber gesprochen der sagte dass für ihn die besten,
Arbeiterinnen sind die eher einen mütterlichen Typ haben also nicht,
in Anführungszeichen Sexbombe die irgendwelche Porno Fantasien.
Verkörpern sondern es sind gerade mütterliche Typen oder beste Freundin Typen die eine,
Stammkundschaft haben weil sie quasi so eine Therapeutinnen Funktion haben und das sind alles sehr interessante überlegungen und ich glaube dieses Thema Sex und käuflicher Sex wird uns sehr beschäftigen.
Und so ist dieser Text ein ganz guter Einstieg in der Republik.
Bei der CS war dies das erste Mal Sex auch vertreten als eigene Business-Bereich.
Ja.
Eigene Toys die mit dem Smartphone steuerbar sind und all das.
Klar Reglementierung wie So ein Messestand auszusehen hat aber es war eben Thema weil die Technik da so einzieht.
Ein weiterer Text der im Doppelpack daherkommt ist von Larry Fink Blackrock Chef und der mächtigste Mann der Welt oder Mensch der Welt.
Er nennt seinen Brief Fundamente Stepping auf Finanz und genauso ist auch gedacht es geht um ein fundamentales neu Sortierung der Finanzwelt.
Und dieser Text geht eben einher damit dass auch das Black Rocks globale Exekutiv-Komitee einen Brief schrieb.
Zur gleichen Zeit indem sie noch einmal Nachhaltigkeit als Black Rocks neuen Standard vor Investing propagieren das heißt wirklich ganz konkret Return on Investment Mathematik.
Ein australisches coolere Reserve fällt zu sehen und zu wissen.
Da muss man mit so viel Material und Mannschaft rein und dann kriegt man so viel raus und der Marktpreis bleibt hoffentlich stabil und wird jetzt ausgetauscht gegen die GEE Komponente.
Das steht für das Social und das G für Governance.
Diese drei Komponenten kann man nicht sagen es ist halt der typische Compliance Sprecher der jetzt überall so vor sich geht aber hier geht es konkret um Finanz Rechnungen und die ganzen Indexfonds z.B. BlackRock hat ja bisher Märkte abgebildet.
Mit diesen Eichhorst kriegen diese Komponente auch.
Also es gibt jetzt ein Rating für Nachhaltigkeit und je nachdem auch wenn man nach wirtschaftsstarken noch groß ist wird man trotzdem runter gerechnet.
Der Anteil von nicht nachhaltig also z.B.
Alle fossilen Brennstoff verzehrenden Unternehmen wird dann einfach runter gerechnet dass da wirklich weniger Geld auch in diesen Investments fragen wenn man nochmal in Kohle Loch buddeln will oder beispielsweise ein Atomkraftwerk bauen.
Dann muss man neue Finanzierungsquellen finden weil die hier wird sie selten ergeben.
Interessanterweise Brexit ist jetzt durch. Während wir das aufnehmen müssen. Also wir können ja jetzt wo wir hier sitzen sagen Morgen ist Brexit.
Die Briten hatten noch ein Problem zu klären und der Europäische Gerichtshof hat der britischen Regierung recht gegeben.
Dürfen darf der Staat ein Atomkraftwerk mitfinanzieren.
Er wurde das letzte Mal sozusagen in England nochmal ein Atomkraftwerk durchgewunken.
Die Frage ist die da geklärt werden musste darf der britische Staat Subventionen leisten oder geht man da irgendwelchen Gleichheitsgrundsatz und so weiter.
Untergräbt untergräbt man die letzte öffentliche Finanzierung eines Atomkraftwerks sowas ist schon umstritten demnächst wird es private Gelder auch rausgezogen und so weiter und fort.
Da ist einiges in Bewegung und Larry Fink schreibt nun meine lieben sie aus Atomkraftwerk.
Atomkraft oder Kohlekraftwerke Atomkraft.
Naja die Briten haben jetzt nochmal einen weiteren Reaktor für ein bestehendes Ding aufgebaut gleichzeitig auch in der Nordsee 1,2 Gigawatt von heute auf morgen angeschaltet Bauzeit drei Jahre für einen großen Windpark.
Da ist ganz schön viel los außer Kohle sind ja damals schon mit Thatcher ausgestiegen. Es ist lange her.
Wilfing schreit Liebe sie aus.
Ich investiere Jahr für andere ist ja Treuhändern und ich will euch jetzt mitteilen was die anderen denken.
Er argumentiert sozusagen als Mittelsmann zwischen den Geldgebern und Sohne wie alle wisst und so weiter.
Project for Future Es gibt die Kulisse für die Argumente die dann kommen.
Schon im zweiten Absatz dann Der Klimawandel ist jetzt der definierende Faktor für alle Langzeit Kalkulationen die man macht Klimawandel muss immer mit betrachtet werden.
Bei Langzeit Investitionen aus Climate Change Climate Risk und damit auch ein Invest Investment Risiko und er stellt sich ebenso fragen und damit auch seinen Lesern.
Angenommen man hat einen 30 Jahres Kredit auf ein Gebäude kann man sich noch leisten da das Klima nicht einzurechnen Wenn schon solche Stadtplanung wie du es gemacht werden müssen.
Klar schöner Seeblick aber was ist in 30 Jahren. Der Kredit ist noch nicht abgezahlt aber der Keller schon immer überflutet. Da muss man jetzt mal drüber nachdenken.
Es gibt bisher das erwähnter dann ausdrücklich dafür keinerlei Studien,
für 30 Jahre Absicherung eines Kredits für ein Gebäude in prominenter Lage also nah am Wasser im urbanen Zentrum gibts überhaupt gar keine Studien die das Klima Risiko betrachten.
Und das wird sich jetzt ändern. Wir brauchen jetzt diese Studien.
Es wird kein Investment mehr gemacht oder bzw. Er ruft dazu auf bitte da nicht irgendwie Geld reinstecken wenn er nicht wisst was in 30 Jahren mit diesen Kellern ist wenn er da so teure Gebäude baut.
Er nennt ausdrücklich die hoch Risikogebieten nah am Wasser also alle urbanen Zentren.
Und dann hat er so eine interessante Frage Wie kalkuliert man eigentlich Wachstum in Schwellenländern. Wenn jetzt plötzlich diese Sommer so extrem und lang werden.
Die Schwellenländer haben ja eine gewisse niedrige Resilienz.
Da fällt so eine Zivilisation mal schneller zusammen wenn es drei Wochen lang 45 Grad ist oder wie in Bagdad 50 Grad so der Standard Temperatur ist auf.
Wir müssen uns das angucken und dann was geschieht mit Inflation Klammer auf Zinsen.
Wenn Nahrungsmittel krass im Preis steigen so wie Lagarde vorhin schon mit Wohnungsmarktes haut uns da ganz schön verfälscht die Inflationsraten wissen das eigentlich wenn wir so langfristig mit Nahrungsmitteln und so weiter.
Weil wenn eine Dürre kommt werden die Nahrungsmittel steigen können wir jetzt diese Nahrungsmittel Kostensteigerung einfach ins BIP einrechnen und sagen es aber cool dass wir mehr Umsatz gemacht haben.
Oder hängt also ein kleiner Rattenschwanz dran und die Richtung geht ja da.
Climate Risk Investment Risk schreibt ausdrücklich Es steht eine große Umverteilung von Kapital an.
Die Märkte werden sich und das finde ich interessant schneller bewegen als das Klima.
Man soll auch darauf aufpassen dass man nicht zu spät kommt zur Party also nicht erst wenn das Wasser im Keller steht dann ist zu spät da muss man nicht mehr hier versuchen teilzunehmen.
Die wichtigste Frage der kommenden Jahre wie die Regierung mit dem Klimaproblem umgehen so wie Lagarde auch Sie sagte Ja auch ich kenne mein Mandat und die Frage die ich mir stelle ist warum kümmer ich mich doch eigentlich die Aufgabe der Politiker.
Und er sagt jetzt Ja das ist die wichtigste Frage wie die Politiker damit umgehen damit einhergehend neue Rahmenbedingungen die auch Investitionen betreffen wenn neue Zollschranken kommen und so weiter wird uns das alle betreffen deswegen nicht mehr blindlings am Klima vorbei irgendwie investieren.
Ausdrücklich sagte er Das ist die Technologie die Gesellschaften günstig macht die ökonomische Kategorien günstig.
Ich sage jetzt friedlich sozusagen im Gleichschritt durch diese Energie Transformation laufen zu lassen gibt es noch nicht.
Auch da soll man aufpassen dass man nicht technische Anschlüsse zu früh außen vor lässt in Europa oder vor allem in Deutschland wieder sehr viel an verschiedenen Batterie getestet. Und er legt den Fokus drauf.
Wir brauchen hier noch eine Technologie wenn sie also irgendeine wahnwitzige Idee wie z.B. in Jena machen die Batterien aus Plastik oder so.
Dann fahren sie dahin und gucken Sie sich das an und sagen nicht einfach mit Plastik kann man nicht Stromspeicher an sondern da wo man jetzt wirklich drauf achten auf sowas und dann im Finale und das ist eigentlich im Finale schreibt.
Ich habe viele Krisen mitgemacht Inflation in den 70ern und 80ern Asienkrise Dotcom Bubble Finanzkrise das war alles Short Term Klimakrise ist jetzt long term.
Nichts davon kennen wir von irgendwo her müssen uns jetzt wirklich neu ausrichten.
In der Hinsicht ein wirklich zu kräftiger Text.
Verfolgt auch die Stakeholder Value Idee ein langfristiges Investieren.
Anders gedacht Shareholder Value kurzfristige Gewinne schnell wieder woanders hin zu springen. Das ist hier nicht zu sehen.
Das ist erstaunlich so einer Klarheit ist und hier sieht man auch einmal mehr dass die Wirtschaft viel weiter denkt und viel nachhaltiger denken kann auch weil sie nicht gewählt ist.
Genau. Ihr könnt ja in 30.
Er kann schreiben was er will er bleibt ja der mächtige Mann.
Während jeder Ministerpräsident zittert werde ich aber gewählt und die Bundesregierung sagt dem Ministerpräsidenten ja bloß nicht die Kohlekraft sondern das schlägt alles nach Berlin zurück.
Und dann kann ich nichts machen das ist auch ein großes Problem das diese Leute haben ohne gewählt zu sein.
Aber Das ermöglicht ihnen eben diese langfristige Denkweise.
Womit man es deutlich machen kann warum die Wirtschaft ein Interesse daran hat das Klima zu halten.
Das ist nicht nur hier um Greenwashing ist ein ganz einfaches Beispiel.
Die Wirtschaft begünstigt Menschen mit Kindern.
Leute die Kinder haben in einem Betrieb arbeiten verdienen meistens etwas mehr. Sie stehen auch auf so einer sozial.
Wenn es zu Entlassungen kommt werden Leute die jetzt drei Kinder zu Hause haben in der Regel nicht als erstes entlassen Singles und so weiter.
Warum könnte man sich fragen denn die Argumentation könnte ja auch sein dass jemand der keine Kinder hat,
der kann ja viel mehr für das Unternehmen da sein er denkt nicht in der Mittagspause oder morgens während er am Computer sitzt an seine Kinder und lässt sich Fotos schicken sondern ganz für die Arbeit leben.
Aber die Wirtschaft oder der Kapitalismus viel mehr ist auf Reproduktion angewiesen er ist darauf angewiesen dass es weitergeht.
Er braucht die langfristige Perspektive generell. Er kann nicht sagen wir mal bis nächstes Jahr und mal gucken ob dann alles zusammenbricht.
Also braucht er auch Nachwuchs der am Ende wieder für den Kapitalismus arbeitet in irgendeiner Weise. Und ähnliches gilt auch für die Natur.
Die Natur muss in irgendeiner Weise sein und ich meine dass gerade nicht so negativ sondern muss vorhanden sein als Ressource.
Deswegen ist auch dem Kapitalismus in gewissem Maße zumindest daran gelegen dass das auch in Zukunft so bleibt ob das für alle dann so sein wird.
Das ist wieder eine andere Frage denn das muss ja nicht eine menschenfreundliche Form des Klimaschutzes am Ende sein.
Einen Ausbeutung ist in der Soziologie ein ganz funktionaler Begriff.
Um nicht zu sagen objektiv oder neutral aber solche benutzt solche Worte benutzt man nicht nur Soziologie. Rein funktional.
Und natürlich die ökonomie ist ein Teil der Gesellschaft sie kennt eine Umwelt und so wie wir bisher die fossilen Ressourcen als Energielieferant hatten,
ist klar dass es auf Kohle und öl musste bisher Dasein damit so funktioniert.
Man muss Rücksicht auf Umwelt nehmen. Die Frage ist Ausbeutung im moralischen Sinne mit positiven oder negativen kennzeichnen Vorzeichen Das muss neu sortiert werden.
Ein langer langer Text der,
zum Abschluss nochmal einen besonderen Charakter hat denn er ist nicht dieser typische leergefischt ist bei dir im Unternehmen mit 100 Prozent investiert also kann er bei der Hauptversammlung irgendwelche Befehle loswerden sondern es ist ganz,
postheroischen typische Manager Text,
erwähnte der ins Haus und du liest und du bist dann auch alarmiert.
Aber du weißt nicht genau was jetzt von ihr verlangt wird das musst du dann schon selber rausfinden sondern es ist sollte die Alarmglocken läuten.
Aber ein Arbeitsauftrag kannst du da noch nicht herauslesen Du musst du schon selber in die Verantwortung gehen.
Unter der Maßgabe ist es wirklich ein interessanter Text weil er auch wirklich unendlich lang ist.
Visionen üblicherweise kennt man ja so Die Jahresrhythmus Texte zu Weihnachten oder so was dann nochmal genau wo man so ein bisschen durchblättert und dann schwingt er aus.
Fröhliche Seiten durchblättert,
aber jetzt anders. Länger ist zugkräftige eben in diesem alarmistischen Charakter.
Aber hier ist anders Er ist länger und er ist zugkräftige. Und eben in diesem alarmistischen Charakter irgendwie gehalten.
Also ein interessantes Ding jetzt im Januar 2020 auch ganz gut platziert für ein Jahr frei. Alles passt irgendwie ins Gefüge.
Interessantes denken jetzt im Januar 2002 auch ganz gut platziert für ein breites Publikum,
ein Kontrapunkt dazu ist ein Text aus Le Monde diplomatique aus der deutschen Ausgabe ist eine Monatszeitschrift die sich mit Weltpolitik und Weltwirtschaft auseinandersetzt und die ich immer gerne lese.
Wo immer großartige Artikel zu finden sind hier auch einer der auch online zu finden ist Australien.
Dieser Artikel beschäftigt sich auf zwei großen Zeitungsseiten lange langes Scrollen im Internet,
mit Australien und mit der dort gerade stattfindenden Katastrophe die aber eine längere Geschichte hat wird dort ein bisschen aufgeholt in diesem Text.
Es geht auch darum wie man zwar Australien immer noch als das Land der Koalas darstellt aber die Politik eben eine vollkommen andere ist.
Das krasse Gegenteil zu dem was du jetzt gerade vorgelesen hast und ein Text der zeigt wie katastrophal diese Politik sich jetzt gerade auswirkt und wie man immer weiter versucht jetzt auch,
die Biodiversität im Meer immer weiter einzudämmen weiß man noch lauter Eingriffe wo man glaubt dort findet man noch fossile Energien.
Dort kann man noch etwas ausbeuten ohne auch nur absehen zu können was das für das gesamte Gleichgewicht dort bedeutet.
Ein Text der nochmal so einen großen Abriss bietet aber eigentlich ganz schön ist um einzuordnen was wir da gerade in Australien sehen das,
sehr nüchtern beschreibt wie katastrophal die Lage ist und dass offenbar auch trotz dieser Katastrophe da erst einmal nichts ändern wird weil die Politik da keinerlei Interesse daran hat.
Aus dreien wird glaube ich auch viele Historiker nochmal interessieren oder auch Politikwissenschaftler.
Auf der einen Seite haben die Kohle Reserven für 800 Jahre die Klimakatastrophe nicht gäbe wenn die Quantenmechanik nicht dazu führen würde dass das CO2 Molekül die Sonnenwärme festhält an der in der Luft hängt.
Dann hätten die gar kein Problem das nach 800 Jahre genau so zu machen die Energie zu exportieren die exportieren die Kohle ist ja nicht der Eigenbedarf.
Gleichzeitig arbeiten aber nicht besonders viele während das Great Barrier Reef mit dem ganzen Tourismus 300 000 Leute Beschäftigung hält und dies aber nicht hinbekommt es so,
politisch zu formalisieren daraus ein Argument zu machen und einfach Arbeitsplätze zu schützen weil das Great Barrier Reef das es jetzt zu spät hat sind jetzt 90 Prozent zerstört.
Die versuchen noch mit Teppichen das Licht irgendwie fernzuhalten und die eine oder andere Reaktion da noch ein bisschen zu verzögern aber das ist im Grunde jetzt vorbei. Gleichzeitig buddeln sie weiter in dieser Kohle.
Abenteuerlich verrückt geradezu.
Gut ein Text oder zwei Text hier kommen wieder zwei Texte im Gleichschritt. Das ist wirklich merkwürdig.
Deutschlands Schuldenquote droht gefährlich zu schrumpfen. Das ist ein sehr rechtlicher Text.
Christian Christian Rainer Mann hat im Spiegel,
geschrieben Ich lese mal vor wegen schwarzer Null und Schuldenbremse steht Deutschland vor einem dramatischen Schuldenabbau seiner Staatsverschuldung,
die Schuldenquote also der Anteil der Staatsverschuldung am Bruttoinlandsprodukt könnte auf lange Sicht von derzeit rund 60 Prozent auf zehn Prozent sinken und sich dort einpendeln heißt es in einer noch unveröffentlichten Studie der Bertelsmann-Stiftung,
die dem SPIEGEL in Auszügen vorliegt.
So habt ihr Wohlstand für alle kürzlich auch mal die Bedeutung von Staatsverschuldung als sicherer Hafen für Geld und die Garantie des Vermögens von Geld kann man sich nicht wegdenken.
Irgendwer muss den Dollar und den Euro stützen und es können nun mal nur die Staaten sein von denen wir sicher sind die machen sich nie aus dem Staub.
Deutschland bleibt einfach hier und das ist absolut verrückt was hier steht dass Deutschland mit 10 prozent Verschuldung und sich dort einpendelt im Vergleich dazu ist auch die Bertelsmann-Stiftung.
Defizit der Krankenkassen steigt bis 2040 auf fast 50 Milliarden Euro.
Wir haben einen Schuldenstand der Staatsverschuldung die nach unten geht und während gleichzeitig ein Minus bei den Sozialabgaben.
Weil das Prinzip Arbeit als Finanzierungsquelle für den Sozialstaat nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und jetzt frage ich mich so ein bisschen wenn man beides zusammenbringt diese Zahlen beide von der Bertelsmann-Stiftung zum Thema Staatsschulden und gleicher Zeithorizont 2040 50 Milliarden Defizit.
Müsste man jetzt könnte man daraus ein Argument stricken.
Vielleicht sehen wir das in diesem Jahrzehnt muss eigentlich irgendwas muss sich da bewegen,
dass man vom Prinzip Arbeit wegkommt dass man sagt wir schaffen Sozialabgaben als eigenen Topf ab und haben nur noch den allgemeinen Steuertopf finanzieren über den auch den Sozialstaat nicht mehr Umlagesystem.
Du musst erst in diese Versicherung einzahlen und dann etwas raus sondern man hat grundsätzlich einen allgemeinen Topf aus dem man Sozialabgaben bezahlt der aber nicht auf der einen Seite nur die Arbeit kennt,
sondern beispielsweise auch Kapital Abschöpfungen oder sonstiges.
Und das war genau der revolutionäre Schritt der fehlt.
Also Arbeit menschliche Arbeit wieder zu ermöglichen dort auch die Löhne allein dadurch zu steigern dass es eben nicht in alle Richtungen nochmal irgendwelche Töpfe abgeführt wird,
und trotzdem beispielsweise über eine dann notwendige Staatsverschuldung die Deutschland wieder in das vertragliche,
Niveau holt nämlich von 100 auf 60 Prozent.
Also so wie ich das hier lese ginge es darum oder wäre es möglich dass Deutschland den ganzen Sozialstaat den man hat über Staatsverschuldung finanziert,
also um Steuern zu umkommt damit das Problem der Sozialabgaben löst und gleichzeitig auch das Problem von Inflation angeht weil man über Staatsschulden sehr gut Inflation steuern kann in denen sich des,
Wahnsinns Dinge einfach mal so gut machen.
Mal ist eine Studie aufgekommen Ich habe mal drei Absätze dazu scheint mir hier sehr viel Material dazulegen Wahnsinn eigentlich aber gut wurde so gemeldet wie man das halt macht wenn die Bertelsmann-Studie irgendwas veröffentlicht.
Wir wissen ja auch nicht ob sich da nicht doch mal jemand verrechnet hat.
Ich will zum Schluss etwas Literarisches empfehlen und dachte mir ist es doch ganz schön wenn ich hin und wieder was aus den 20er Jahren empfehle Literatur die es sich lohnt jetzt wieder zu lesen in den neuen 20er Jahren und ich dachte mir ich nehme ein Buch,
das jetzt genau hundert Jahre alt geworden ist In Stahlgewittern von Ernst Jünger Ernst Jünger hat im Ersten Weltkrieg gekämpft hat dort ein Kriegstagebuch geführt und hat daraus dann kondensiert dieses seines berühmten sein berühmtestes Buch In Stahlgewittern.
Und ich würde einfach mal den Anfang vorlesen.
Denn es ist wunderbar man bekommt ein Gespür dafür was Ernst Jünger so ausgemacht hat in seinem Schreiben.
Der Zug hielt in einem Städtchen der Champagne Wir stiegen aus mit ungläubiger Ehrfurcht lauschten wir den langsamen Takten des Walzwerk der Front,
eine Melodie die uns in langen Jahren Gewohnheit werden sollte.
Ganz weit floss der weiße Ball eines Schrapnell im grauen Dezember Himmel.
Der Atem des Kampfes wehte herüber und ließ uns seltsam erschauern.
Ahnten wir dass fast alle von uns verschlungen werden sollten an Tagen in denen das dunkle murren brandete unaufhörlich rollendem Donner.
Der eine früher der andere später.
Wir hatten Hörsäle Schulbänke Tische verlassen und waren in den kurzen Ausbildungsweg zu einem großen begeisterten Körper zusammengeschmolzen.
Aufgewachsen in einem Zeitalter der Sicherheit fühlten wir alle die Sehnsucht nach dem Ungewöhnlichen nach der großen Gefahr.
Da hatte uns der Krieg gepackt wie ein Rausch in einem Regen von Blumen waren wir herausgezogen in einer trunkenen Stimmung von Rosen und Blut.
Der Krieg musste es uns ja bringen das große starke feierliche erschien uns männliche Tat.
Ein fröhliches schützen. Gefecht auf blumigen Wiesen.
Da ist schon alles auf der ersten Seite zu erfahren was Ernst Jünger ausmacht was ihn.
Großartig macht. Ich bin ja ein begeisterter Ernst Jünger Leser wenngleich auch ein kritischer.
Das Großartige bei Ernst Jünger ist dass er ein sehr reflektierter Autor ist und auch sprachlich darüber reflektiert wie diese Heroisierung stattfindet.
Er ist aber auch jemand der den Krieg immer wieder ins natürliche umschlagen lässt.
Es ist ja anfangs gar nicht erkennbar hört man dort Geräusche aus der Natur oder sind es die der Front.
Er vermischt das alles sehr schön und der Krieg ist bei ihm so wird es auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg bei ihm sein vor allem ein ästhetisches Schauspiel das er von einer merkwürdig unsympathischen Distanz heraus beobachtet.
Dem er aber zugleich auch selbst teilnimmt.
Dieses Buch aber auch davon zeugt dass es diese Sehnsucht gibt nach der Gefahr einer Sehnsucht die uns heute,
wieder auftaucht und damit meine ich nicht dass manche Extremsportler so neigen um sich mal wieder zu spüren oder Tätowierungen sich machen lassen um sich zu spüren.
Sondern es gibt auch und gerade bei den neuen Rechten diesen Wunsch,
nach einem Ende der Diskussion nach einem Ende der Spaßgesellschaft und wieder ein heiliger Ernst stattfindet der dann auch mit einer Gewalt und dem sich selbst opfern verbunden ist.
Das kann man also auch dieses Buch zur Abschreckung lesen.
Es ist aber auf jeden Fall ein literarisch sehr sehr wichtiges Werk und das sollte man wenn man sich mit den 20er Jahren und auch mit dieser Emphase für den Ersten Weltkrieg,
ein bisschen in den Zweiten Weltkrieg wieder,
Ernst Jünger war auch ein geschätzter Autor im Dritten Reich.
Um das nachzuvollziehen ist es glaube ich sehr gut sich mit diesem Text nochmal auseinander zu setzen auf den sich ganz viele bezogen haben die danach Literatur geschrieben haben.
Der Unendliche Spaß kann ja wohl nicht alles sein. So eine Denke die ja immer steckt. Man muss sich das Vergnügen verdienen.
Das ist so. Und seis im Krieg. Da geht es wenigstens noch um was um Leben und Tod.
Zum Abschluss zwei Texte die Filme betreffen eine vor der Leinwand Jason Fried war im Kino und seine überschrift lautet The Movie and the Future.
Er sitzt im Kino ich referierte kurz. Er hat es ganz wunderbar geschrieben ist so ein richtig schönes schönes Stück Literatur so als gäbe es noch Weblogs und so.
Er geht also ins Kino der Film läuft an. Nach 20 Minuten geht hinten irgendwie es knistert.
Keine Ahnung irgendwas ist mit der Filmrolle alles digital aber es stimmt ja nicht alle gucken sich an die erste Frage kommt auf sitzt da oben noch einer der das auch sieht oder müssen wir uns jetzt irgendwo melden.
Problem geht nicht weg. Ich stehe nach fünf Minuten der erste auf.
Und er geht raus aus dem Kinosaal und trifft niemanden auf den weiten Fluren des Kinos an um Bescheid zu sagen dass der Film nicht funktioniert,
biegt um die Ecke geht zur Kasse sitzt auch keiner mehr alle Filme laufen Zwicker keiner Popcorn kaufen hier ist einfach niemand in diesem Kino. Der Film ist kaputt.
Also klopft er an irgendwelche Türen. Vielleicht steckt hinter den Türen noch jemand der sich auskennt.
Dann trifft er auf Techniker und sieht das Problem schon gesehen und die versuchen das auch schon zu lösen.
Und jetzt sagen die mir auch hier ist uns bekannt wir kümmern uns darum geht er wieder zurück in Kinosaal.
Film beginnt nach 30 Minuten einfach von vorne. Keiner bekommt was gesagt nichts passiert.
Gefilmt beginnt einfach vorne keiner die Lust nochmal die ersten 30 Minuten zu sehen. Also geht man raus.
Und dann beginnt das zweite Drama Man will sein Geld zurück weil es wurde nicht geliefert was versprochen wurde für das Geld und das kann man dann nachlesen im Text.
Ob man noch einen Ansprechpartner zumindest für dieses Problem findet. Irgendwann muss doch nochmal in dieser hoch automatisierten Welt für Probleme zuständig sein.
Das ist ein toller toller Text der wie auch andere als Chiffre einfach dient.
Irgendwas fällt aus dem Standard. Der Standard kann mittlerweile ökonomisch super abgedeckt werden.
Aber sobald man die Korridore des Erwartbaren verlässt steht man auf weiter Flur und ist einfach verloren.
Der andere Text den fand ich einfach nur interessant auch unter Hinblick auf Rentner Republik. Das ist gar kein besonders großer Text.
Ich würde sagen es ist einfach ein kurzes Porträt geschrieben über irgendjemanden den man nicht kennt.
Dieser Jemand ist also eine Schauspielerin aus Japan Place Films Musik und Art Film Musik und Kunst da hat diese Person ihren Platz gefunden Frage in der Gesellschaft auch. Es ist wirklich verrückt.
Es ist eine japanische Schauspielerin die sich sehr darüber freut dass sie inzwischen unsichtbar geworden ist. Sie will farblos leben.
Sie zieht sich an wie Rentner irgendwie beige und daraus zerrt sie ihre Selbstsicherheit.
Man fragt sich so wie fühlten sich das zusammen.
Like The Feeling pur und transparent.
Ich möchte gern als unberührbar sowieso unschuldig unsichtbar gelten und Lucent ist das Wort das hier immer wieder fällt der Karlos. Ich kämpfe gegen die Farben.
Das ist eine ganz komische Herangehensweise dafür dass ich als Schauspielerin sich eigentlich davon lebt sich so zu exponieren.
Aber sie möchte gerne so ganz mit sich selbst leben.
Und da dieser Text so auf dieses Selbstsicherheit.
Als die Quelle des Selbstsicherheit der Selbstsicherheit ist die sie sich möglichst verstecken unsichtbar seien nicht angreifbar sein.
Gerade das Duckmäuser Rescher als Quelle der Selbstsicherheit aber eben ganz expressiv vorgetragen fand ich wirklich verrückt ich mag mich so ein bisschen daran erinnert.
Emma Watson zum Beispiel als etwas prominentere Schauspielerin bei uns hat ja auch dieses neue Prinzip sie lebt.
Sie ist nicht Single sondern sie hat diese Definition von selbst eben nicht aus der Perspektive eines anderen.
Es gibt eine ganz weitreichende Soziologie zur Liebe wie man sich so gegenseitig Veld Entwürfe bestätigt und den anderen darin bestätigt sich richtig zu verhalten und daraus ein gemeinsames erwächst.
Und hier ist es einfach sich selbst Selbstgenügsamkeit.
Komischer Umgang der allerdings in der Folge von John Brennan,
trainiert Konflikte auf Leute besitzen einfach nichts mehr sie haben keine Kampfmaschine mehr sie haben nichts mehr zu verlieren und so weiter.
Und mittlerweile scheint sich das so durchzuschlagen dass man einfach Vorbild dafür ist auch eine neue Art von Selbstgenügsamkeit zu propagieren.
Die Farblosigkeit besteht in Durchsichtigkeit Duckmäuser.
Auch modisch niederschlägt. Es gibt da einige neue Modefirmen die sehr stark auf Farben rausnehmen die Farben Schattierungen nehmen die so unauffällig sind wie eine Hauswand.
Hausband.
Damit meine ich nicht nur die Rentner Kleidung sondern auch junge Mode. Das ist ein gewisser Trend der vor paar Jahren eingesetzt hat und man möchte anonym leben können.
Direktvergleich Mode. Das ist ein gewisser Druck der vor ein paar Jahren eingesetzt hat.
Man möchte anonym leben können dann aber für sich sein.
Aber es geht nicht dass es so einen Diskurs aus den alten Zwanzigerjahren um so ein Aufgehen in der Masse dass man so ein Körper wird so hat Ernst Jünger vor sich auch in seinen späteren Schriften und Essays.
Es geht also nicht dass es zu einem Diskurs aus den 20er Jahren um so ein Aufgehen in der Masse also dass man so einen Körper wird so was ernst vor sich auch in seinen späteren Schriften noch sagt.
Aber was wir jetzt hier erleben ist eigentlich dass man sagt Ich ziehe mich auf mein individuelles zurück und das kann ich am besten indem ich nicht mehr auffalle und ungestört.
Aber was wir jetzt hier erleben ist eigentlich dass man sagt Ich ziehe mich auf mein individuelles zurück und das kann ich am besten indem ich nicht mehr auffalle und ungestört mich bewegen kann.
Verrückt aber auch Ausdruck von irgendwas was sich so langsam Bahn bricht und na ja das werden wir ja hier aufspüren.
Was ja.
Das kann man im Januar Blaustein abgehandelt so viel Lesestoff verlegen und damit auch.
Damit haben wir den Januar glaub ich gut abgehandelt zu insgesamt.
Alles ist verlinkt was jetzt genannt haben und damit auch zur Lektüre empfohlen.
Außer Ernst Jüngers Buch Das muss man dann schon selber kaufen tragen und durchblättern das Lesen noch Arbeit fernab des Bildschirms.
Ja das wollen wir noch gedruckt lesen.
Sehr gut. Im Februar wieder wer jetzt schon Februar ist aber dann auch zum thematischen Februar gibt den meteorologischen Februar den kalendarischen und den 20er-Jahre Februar zu dem uns Wiederhören haut rein.
Uns geht es aber dann auch zum thematischen methodologischen kalendarischen und den 20er Jahren zu dem Wiederhören.
Intro